busy hey before we go i wanted to say a
special thank you and congratulations to
ken
hutchins over at the regional
transportation commission he's one of
the great men and women that worked
there
adjusting all those cameras for us and
keeping an eye on the traffic signals
he's retiring today so
ken happy retirement on your last day at
the rtc john congratulations to you ken
good stuff
6 49 now on a thursday morning hustler
founder larry flint
has died he passed away in his home in
los angeles yesterday at the age of 78.
flint built a business empire with
hustler magazine becoming one of the
biggest names in adult entertainment
flint launched hustler back in 1974 and
he launched a number of clubs as well
through the 2000s including
one right here in las vegas by the strip
alex
cbs this morning begins here at the top
of the hour in about 10 minutes and we
have gayle king joining us
live this morning with what they are
working on good morning to you gail have
you defrosted out there in new york
no not yet not just put on your winter
coat it's called winter in new york but
before we get started i want to say
congratulations to ken hutchins too
i just heard that he's retiring and it
must be nice to be re it
must be nice to be retiring and know
people that wish you well and are
cheering you on so i say
congratulations to you mr ken hutchins
absolutely
absolutely very good at your job that's
amazing reliable sources listening to
you guys
okay here we go ahead on cbs this
morning striking new video shows just
how close to danger lawmakers were
during the assault on the capital
democrat on the capitol period
democratic senator amy klobuchar joins
us with her reaction to this new
evidence in former president trump's
impeachment trial
it's very disturbing if you watched it
yesterday a lot of us did
also one million doses of covet vaccine
they're on the way to retail pharmacies
across the country
maybe it's coming to your neighborhood
we'll discuss new cdc guidelines
to improve protection from the
coronavirus and it involves wearing a
mask
not one but two and the popular dating
site that's bumble
going public today first on cbs this
morning
we'll introduce you to the founder who
will be making history as the youngest
female ceo ever to take a company public
wait till you hear how old whitney wolf
whitney wolf heard is her name it's
going to be a good day for her
we'll see you at seven o'clock that's
about nine minutes from now
yes to you guys and if ken retiring
wasn't exciting enough
gail getting a shout out from you i
think is the cherry on top so thank you
so much for that
you have a great show ken doesn't care
he doesn't care that i said anything
about him but i was excited to hear good
news i crave good news these days
yes don't we all all right well thanks
so much gail you have a great morning
we'll be right back all right